let's get the headlines a former teacher
in Kentucky a gym teacher by the name of
crystal Graham was charged with
disorderly conduct after an incident in
gym class where she threatened to cut
off a student's dick and shove it down
his throat during a kickball game during
a kickball game I missed that important
detail the student jumped on another
student's back this was this was a boy
who just kind of jumped on another kid's
back they were horsing around and she
yelled at him I will cut off your dick
and shove it down your throat
and how did this make the news like okay
so she got fired fairly soon after that
or she had to retire after this became
public
but now she's being charged with a crime
I think one of the kids involved in the
crime complained which is kind of a weak
move that you know that she did this she
not only you know said that she would
cut off his dick and shove it down his
throat she did a double bird middle
finger style double hands
she must have having a rough day I mean
imagine imagine just being in charge of
a kickball game and having that thought
and then hanging out loud at a child
that you were gonna cut off their dick
like by the way it's a middle school it
was not a high school as in middle
school she was she was 34 years old at
the time yeah that's even worse yeah the
older the person the more they can
handle having their penis cut off and
shut down with no but when you're the
developmental age in middle school I
just don't think there's any room for it
and that's why I would never let my kid
play kickball people talk about
concussions in the NFL but when you talk
about look at the numbers the people who
get who are getting their dicks cut off
and shut down their own throats it's all
kickball I don't know what it is about
kickball but but the injury rate is
sky-high and it's almost always it's
almost always a penis being cut off and
then shoved down the throat just for not
really respecting the game of kickball
wow if your teacher
said to you guys when you were playing
kickball I'm gonna cut your dick off and
shove it down your throat would you say
anything would you tell someone would
you tell your parents would you I would
give her a high five I would listen
first of all if that happened to me in
middle school I would still be laughing
about it right now like I would think it
was the greatest thing that ever
happened to me
it would just delight me that I would
probably tell people in like a couldn't
believe what happened at school we were
playing kickball and the teacher
threatened to cut off my dick and shove
it down my throat I'm like why not just
stop with cutting off the dick but
that's a bet alone is why did you give
the double bird I kind of looked at this
and was just like you know I don't want
to sound like the old man like get off
my lawn stuff but how soft are we
getting as a society that you can't
threaten to cut a kid's dick off and
shove it down their throats are in a
kickball game when we were kids people
were threatening to cut off our dicks
all that happened all the time it
happened I mean the fact that we made it
into our 40s big dicks intact and
knocked down our throat considering the
amount of kickball we played his game I
think is I think it's stunning I don't
know how he wasn't even just kick ball
just like neighbors whoever they would
be yelling at it all the time but we
took it because it was like a different
era but now kids it's like ooh sensitive
feelings and they just go go run to the
teachers it's like well what uh what if
Ellis came home and was like dad I was
playing kickball today and my teacher
yelled at me gave me two middle fingers
and said they'd cut my dick off I feel
like I don't even have a dick that
doesn't make any sense yeah it's it's a
hollow threat right and I and I told you
use your right foot and really kick
through the ball Alice mm-hmm we are
gonna go to the wrestling ring where we
have a tragic story the Silver King who
is a former WCW wrestler who also
starred as the bad guy in the 2006
comedy nacho libre died while in the
wrestling ring last week by a parent
heart attack got knocked down three
different times and then just was kind
of lying there
on the ground and he was 51 years old
his real name was Caesar Barone I liked
the fact that he was supposed to win the
match like you know but professional
wrestling I believe they are athletes
they do it their job is very difficult
they are totally athletes but it is
scripted they know who's gonna win in
advance and this guy was supposed to win
and the guy he's fighting is like trying
to find a way to still lose the match
even though the other guy's dead the guy
did you imagine trying to get someone
who's here watch the video no oh my god
it's the saddest thing I mean it is the
saddest thing ever that you could find
some humor and because of what you're
saying he was the the guy he was
fighting with was clearly so confused
and did not know what to do yeah didn't
know what to do and like and just
couldn't find a way to get the dead guy
to pin him and you know what this is a
sad story but I think that if the silver
King was alive today he would appreciate
it you know I think he'd probably be
like Thank You Anthony
and Greg mmm I'm gonna cut off your dick
I mean it wasn't a few things I learned
watching this video well first of all
it's really hard to roll over a dead
person I mean like he could not get the
guy he was trying to flip him over to
eventually pin him cuz he realized
something was wrong but then here's
where here's where it like gets a little
like tragic comedy he celebrated the
victory for so long he went to each
corner got his own flag out started
waving it the crowd is there it's a
pretty big crowd this is a he's not no
longer in the WCW but wherever they were
he's waving his flag he's celebrating
and and the other wrestler is just lying
there dead in the middle of the ring for
like for like three minutes no but I'm
beginning to think like the medical that
it's not really that safe to be a
wrestler no medical attention whatsoever
being paid to the guy in the ring I mean
I think the dads do they know like I
think they don't know yet but he knew
something was wrong eventually the ref
comes out and tries to take off his mask
and they realize something's wrong and
then some people come out but it
the video just keeps going on and on
he's like like a bad skin if you're a
wrestler when you kill someone I got to
think it's at the top thing you can do
do you know I mean because it is fake
that how often does it happen you know
not not that often and it reminded me of
the movie the wrestler which is a great
movie
yeah ends with him choosing to die in
the ring so maybe this is how the Silver
King wanted to go out you know now it
was with with the guy he was fighting
with the Quags celebrating within an
inch of his life by the wrestler is one
of my favorite movies of all time
everyone imagine how bad the guy felt
when he found out he was dead
yeah celebrating I mean that's that's
what it's truly funny to me is is the
guy well you had to have he didn't have
an idea that the guy was dead but he was
unconscious and he couldn't four minutes
and he had he couldn't roll him over I
don't know what this other guy was
thinking I think I'm like I'm the Silver
King now
[Music]
you